we're back in Miami we're still in Miami
and a guy who's back in Miami who got
his start here with the dolphins before
heading to Cleveland Jarvis Landry back
on the program Jarvis great to see you
buddy good to see you guys the dodgeball
winner and the oh that's right have some
awesome you can throw it I mean I've
seen you kind of let it go now a few
times
yeah but the double catch was more
impressive the quick rapid-fire boom
boom yes the dodgeball is just a little
bit different it's a little little
tougher to handle would like to throw it
to throw so yeah yeah I figured catching
it was the best thing that was your your
your mo right there yeah so how you
feeling after full season of football a
little time to unwind a little time to
decompress get your body right how's
things going heading into the offseason
for you um it going good you know
they're going good just like any season
you know you you lead a season nicked up
bruised up unfortunately I started the
season that way but we managed to get
through the season and now it's just
getting as healthy as possible to you
know be able to start training and go
back at it for another year
so like come on what the hell happened
you know you guys were like one of the
teams we talked about all year I mean
everybody's got this view of you guys
from the outside and everything and
there was a lot of crap that went on
during the year like what was your
assessment of how everything went down
in 2019 um you know it was tough I think
just the talent we have you know that
everybody recognized that we had and and
knowing how close we were to actually
getting over the hump and we just never
quite got there right you know
communication was off you know and and a
lot of times I think in this game you
know we can and we got that's one of the
key things that stays the same
communication has to be great
you know and we didn't have that each
and every week what are you referring to
when you say communication just
communication where you know from from
from plays - you know from receiver to
quarterback or you know whatever
whatever host a quarterback a lot of
elements you know it's a lot of elements
is different than you know I guess she
would say basketball or these other
sports you know football you know every
guy has to be on the same page
do you think that the expectations were
just out of control that was one of the
things I saw coming last year like the
bars too high everyone's too fired up
about what this Browns team can be I
mean let's walk before we sprint and and
I feel like that got out of control and
it kind of contributed to the the extra
stress and the anxiety when it didn't
start off the way it was supposed to
well I mean I think credit to coach
Freddie you know you know he did a great
amazing job of making sure we didn't buy
into any of that that we didn't listen
to it that we ignored the noise and you
know he explained to us how in the
beginning of the season how the only
people that really care about us the
only people that know what we go through
other people that's in this building you
know and everybody can get their
expectations their predictions how good
we're supposed to be and this and that
but that doesn't matter you know what
matters is about the guys that's in this
building you know and that's one thing
that you know I took my hat to him for
because I think we did a great job of
not buying into you know there's Odell
Beckham right there yeah the crap you
know the crap that you know we really
tried to become a team but we just we
just couldn't do it you and Odell back
together I mean that's your buddy I mean
you know he's told me you know when I've
interviewed him he was just so excited
to be with you I think the feeling's
mutual on your side you know what was
the year like and then also like what do
you guys talk about going into 2020 that
you want to change I mean you know it
was tough again you know we both hurt we
both injured he just finished having his
procedure done and he's getting healthy
now and for us it's just understanding
looking back reflecting on the past
season and then understanding what we
could do to get better individually
first and then you know as a team and
how do we bring it together as a team
right you know and again you know it's
never gonna be easy you know it's never
gonna be easy and we understand that but
you know it's up to us to be able to
make the plays and and leave these leave
these guys what would you tell Odell to
come to OTAs this year like to me Jenna
listen I'm an outsider I know I don't
know crap that way but like you know it
seemed like him and Baker or like you
and Baker got a special little
connection I feel like when Baker the
pocket breaks it's like out there he's
gonna find Jarvis and boom there's
Jarvis or 20 yards didn't seem like him
and Odell we're on the same page
sometimes do you attribute that to maybe
him not being around
is um you know I I mean you probably you
probably can say that but I wouldn't say
that you know I think you know Adele has
a great plan for it for his body and
yeah I know he's not sitting on the at
home on the couch working out but I do
what you see in her it misses you know
that the reps right and he misses he
missed the opportunity he misses the
community do one yes right um but I
think you know you add in training camp
you add in the offseason both of the
both of these guys live in LA together
you know they're training together you
know and you add in training camp I
think they're still with time in there
to be able to establish you know that
level of comfort you know which i think
is gonna be there this year
it's third year for you now in Cleveland
and it's gonna be third head coach what
kind of a challenge does that create for
Jarvis Landry knowing everything's gonna
be different again yeah you know for me
I'm one of those type of guys that just
controls what he can control you know I
firmly believe that if I take care of
the things that I take care of you know
it doesn't matter who's calling the
plays doesn't matter who's coaching you
know obviously I respect everybody and
but I know at the end of the day
ultimately I have to handle my business
I'll be replaced you know and that's
what that's all I'm trying to do what
have you heard from Kevin Stefanski that
gets you excited about what the team
could be this year uh man I just ain't
no III love what his head's at man I
love that he's focused on the team you
know he's not not about the job but not
about what we did last year you know
obviously he's gonna go through film and
go through tape you know and evaluate
guys and things like that make
adjustments but you know I like that his
message has been clear and it's been one
message let's just get ready to work
49ers the best team you played this year
who was the best and not who was lost
49ers Baltimore Baltimore yeah yeah so
yeah go ahead which one you think you
like to you I you know I know we know
the 49ers are here in the Superboy you
think the Baltimore was better but just
seeing them on the field this year -
yeah I mean I mean we all saw it you
know we we managed to catch them early
on in the year before they started
clicking right and put
a little bit and you know it then it
seems like after that they woke up
everyone stopped yeah all right yeah all
right why last thing cuz I know we want
to talk about Old Spice and I need to
put a little under my arm so I'm gonna
do that like I've done with everybody
else and he's done it every time he
doesn't understand it goes under the
shirt I don't care what smells good like
what what do people not understand about
Baker Mayfield right I mean I think
there's some people that love them
something calm and he talks too much
yeah like what's what do you think the
assessment is of him in the locker room
he's a leader you know he's one of the
first guys in the building one of the
last guys to leave and you know I know
that's important to me to see that from
a quarterback you know to see you know
the guy who's gonna get the most
criticism no matter what win lose draw
you know he's gonna get the most
criticism you know and that's kind of
been my message to him you know it all
starts with you you know whatever you
want in this building that's what could
happen right so it has to happen right
you know and you know just continue to
the support of me still young in his
career you know he's still growing into
position obviously he's played it for a
while but you know it's the NFL to you
know we gotta do a better job as
receivers and as it seemed you know
making sure that we can help them out
all right all right I mean I know you're
good at receiver but let's see what you
are as a pitchman all right let's see
we'll see how that goes down so we gonna
settle we're gonna settle since this
year you know it's a new product that
they've come out with a little different
than all the other products you know the
feejee which I love the shower gel and
that I love so this is not as since it
yeah you know if you're not really
looking to stand out as much right but
yeah he's like what is wrong with you
like you know crazy Chris and that's it
thank you very much I use all spice all
the time that so I don't smell I smell
good I know I don't have my Old Spice
down I'll take you sure they got extra
huh because I serious it'll take they
got plenty more than I get for the new
red t-shirt how many different ways I
could drop the hint Old Spice I want the
darker red t-shirt it is a nice upgrade
the other red was fine yeah I like this
is sweet I like even the darker red on
here is it's good hey you're one of our
favorite players man your that you
really are you're awesome you're
all-around football player you block you
do it all and I continued success all
right
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports